open your eyes
sheeple dark forces are at work behind
the scenes puppet masters pulling the
strings and controlling everything you
see and hear no not the Knights Templar
the Rosicrucians I mean the hats who
keep using secret societies a shorthand
for evil in their pop cultural products
Dan Brown's latest book Inferno has the
consortium jay-z and Drake named Jeff
the Illuminati and Rick Ross rhymes
about freemasons and the Templars show
up yet again in Assassin's Creed 4 Black
Flag all of these secret societies seem
to fail at their central mission being
secret storytellers are deploying secret
societies far too casually they've
turned into paint-by-numbers super
villains with it a dash of x-files and a
pinch of Alex Jones but what bothers me
more than the laziness is the fact that
this leeches power from actual
conspiracy theories our most vital and
powerful form of modern-day folk art
don't believe me search YouTube for
Illuminati
so that's who force to pop Shakur and
Paul McCartney to fake their own deaths
live and learn
and learn look you can make great art
about secret societies but only if you
make it about the paranoia itself like
echo did with Foucault's Pendulum or
Steve Jackson did with this Illuminati
card game or philip k dick did with with
everything with everything he ever did
ever people who record rants about how
the pyramid on the dollar bill proves
that the trilateral commission controls
Major League Baseball are a national
treasure the movie national treasure is
not a national treasure what's your
favorite conspiracy theory let me and
the NSA know in the comments